[Music]
welcome to coffee Zilla a little D
monetization interview is sort of the
first and is hopefully a series of talks
with creators about how do monetization
has affected them and today I have
Griffin Johnson right okay sorry I want
to make sure get that right the armchair
historian you guys all know him and he
recently had a big big video about being
demonetized and how much his channel is
being hurt basically if you haven't
heard we just keep getting demonetised
over and over again and this means that
ads can't run on the videos and that
they're not gonna be promoted to anybody
um so they're not gonna be recommended
and the views are gonna go really far
down and I can't just keep making videos
like this if that's just gonna keep
happening so I want to stop and then
resolve the issue first if this doesn't
work all this stuff that I've worked for
for multiple years on YouTube will all
fall apart I want to hear from your
words what is give me the history of D
monetization for history shores for a
second alright alright well thanks for
having me on but yeah so I guess that
the history of do monetization within
education and history channels is that
what you're asking cuz I don't know I
can't really speak on all of the
monetization across YouTube but I know
no specifically his just channel yeah
history channels yeah so yeah so when I
started out about three years ago just
uploading now and then quite casually I
don't even think the strict requirements
for monetization were around back then
so if I'm not mistaken I was able to
just monetize right off the bat and so
we're a lot of other educational
channels and no one was really affected
by D monetization that much what I was
saying a while ago was that if you
covered like the Holocaust and you were
bringing out lots of controversy
controversy and inviting that into the
comments section and just overall
creating a very controversial video and
you know it's controversial yeah you'd
run the risk of D monetization that
would happen and other history creators
would you know we could kind of accept
that and but specifically affected
military history channels and
History Channel's who covered World War
two in particular and within World War
two covering genocide and again the
Holocaust and anything that is that we
can acknowledge is controversial so it
wasn't that much of a problem however
over over a couple years
they've they've kind of been I think the
algorithm the way they basically will
find content and flag it if it's if it's
going to be demonetized or not has been
learning YouTube says this themselves
and they've been a lot more liberal with
what kind of videos are being
demonetised so before again like all the
history youtubers could kind of
acknowledge okay yeah I'll have one
video in my catalog that's going to get
to monetize because you're bound to
cover something controversial when you
talk about history but recently within
it within the last few months you've had
creators all around the same time and I
think YouTube is this you know what's
kind of funny about it is YouTube had a
glitch where subscribers would see or
YouTube channels would see their
channels with zero subscribers they are
all getting demonetised at once they try
to remove our verification badges then
they brought them back all of these
changes were kind of happening around
the same time so you can tell that
YouTube was going through some some big
changes recently within the last couple
months and that's when the Great War
Channel all of a sudden 250 videos get
demonetized not even controversial ones
just stop stop for one second sure let
that sink in 250 videos at one time got
demonetized
I can't I can't fathom that that's like
it's way more than my entire catalog oh
I know exactly I've only released like
60 or 70 videos yes so that's that is
like and and you know I what I want to
make very very clear I've been trying to
tell people I don't even like to call it
do monetization it's video suppression
and I know you can speak on this about
your I think you had a video about like
cigarettes and vaping and what will
happen and you can look at the graphs
some people might deny this but we as
the creators we have the analytics
YouTube provides the analytics to show
this a video can be monetized and it can
be up despite what they say they say
unless the video about will check it and
then you can
at public okay you do that it doesn't
get flagged you make it public and then
halfway through its release it can get
too monetized
and you can see the views drop
dramatically and so I don't like to call
it video to monetization because you not
only lose most of the apps running on it
but you lose recommendation because a
few tubes not making money on the ads
that are being run there's no point in
running it why not run the family
family-friendly content that is getting
ads and so your views are going to get
down it's not going to be recommended
some of your subscribers might not even
hear that you release the video and
you're not even making money on it so
when that happens to 250 videos
especially the great the great war
channel if you guys aren't familiar
covers world covered World War one in
real time so you're meant to watch from
beginning to end well if you can't find
videos it's not like they're standalone
and it's like okay if I miss one it's
whatever if you miss 250 videos you're
gonna have no idea what's going on and
again to say that 250 videos are all
controvert like there were no if you
look at World War one compared to World
War two
you at least the everyday person can
point out more atrocities and more
controversy in World War two we're still
having debates about World War two today
there aren't many World War one
political movements going on today you
know there's like people want to talk
about Nazism and communism Stalinism
specifically from world war ii that's
still stuff that affects us today and
world war one a lot of these political
movements aren't really around anymore
so you can I think most people can
objectively say that World War one had
less controversy than World War two at
least that's the way it's covered
there's still things that went on in the
First World War that are controversial
and lots of people being killed and lots
of groups being suppressed of course
that's going on but relative to World
War to World War one's gonna have less
controversy so the fact that 250 videos
got wiped out you can only imagine what
people covering World War two or even
modern events that need to be talked
about are going through and it doesn't
just affect the history community it
affects anyone trying to talk about
education or really more than just
education nerd City released a video
recently talking about how the LGBTQ
community if they even include the word
gay or less
or anything relating to their identities
if they even even include that in the
title their video gets demonetized so
really there's just there's such a large
problem here from from the from even the
title of your video just it can be
completely suppressed even if you're not
talking about controversy if you want to
educate or just talk about something
personal to you YouTube might not allow
it yeah yeah and I want to jump in here
first of all that's actually how I found
Griffin was we both got featured in nerd
city's video that guy is like the hero
of YouTube right now by the way because
he's bringing light in a popular manner
to to the public to let people know
what's actually going on what creators
kind of know but he's really shedding
some light because I mean as you said
nearly every communities getting
affected by this in some way and I think
it is important that we highlight how it
affects fuse cuz I think the views are
actually way more important than
Google's you know add Adsense I mean it
really doesn't do much for most creators
but most creators get supported by is
sponsorships and so really what happens
when your video gets suppressed is not
the loss of ads ahead since it's the
loss of sponsors because you have to for
the people at home how sponsors work as
you say this is how many of you views my
videos get so you guarantee some number
of user you guesstimate some number of
views and if you don't hit those numbers
then they're less likely to work with
you in the future so right having a
video demonetized isn't just about
Adsense it's really about you know if
you get that M rating which we're gonna
get into in a second you're going to get
suppressed and when you get suppressed
you can't have sponsors when you can't
have sponsors you can't grow or you know
expand your channel or really make a
living so it really gets down to that
because I think when the first wave of D
monetization hit it was less about the
suppression Google's ramped up the the
way they're suppressing videos because
they've been under so much fire from all
these different you know we could go
over a million different cases but like
the mainstream media has been hitting
Google hard about like allowing hate
speech you know all these things and
fair enough you know get those things in
check but because of that they've been
trying to crack down on borderline
content
but it seems like there's no consensus
there's no transparency on what that
means I mean III hung on to what
something you said which is like we knew
in the history community sort of what
would get us demonetised
what's so frustrating now is it feels
like no one knows what we'll get oh yeah
no idea like like you could make some
video and you think oh this is you know
this is about as you know PG as it gets
I saw what's that guy's name uber danger
he made a video where he was talking
about how he's like been crippled by
demonization he goes you know I I've
been working to get my videos clean and
still they're getting D monetized I have
no idea why like I think that's a huge
component of is just the seeming
arbitrariness of their rules yeah
there's just no transparency and for
those of you who aren't running YouTube
channels it doesn't tell you why your
video gets you monetized it doesn't even
doesn't even him it just says nope
reviewed cuz that's it that's all the
information you get so that makes it
even more frustrating I think that if
creators had some level of transparency
if at least they were honest and said
yeah we just don't like having worn the
title sorry at least we could try to
respond in some kind of way but you know
there's just no transparency really well
and look if when you get on TV you have
a relationship with standards and
practices and you can call up you can
say hey this is what my video is gonna
look like and they tell you hey at 41
minutes you have this in here they're
not gonna like that you're gonna have
some problems here take that out etc etc
mm-hmm
youtubers need that if this is going to
continue to be a thing if it's not just
about Adsense if it's if it's about
views themselves YouTube needs a way to
basically make creators learn because
just spinning your wheels forever is not
an option yeah III mean like no lie I
always thinks it's a joke when creators
are like I'm thinking about quitting
YouTube I've seen creators like not
joking anymore they're not like doing it
for views they're like seriously like
you know I'm thinking about getting out
of youtube it's just not sustainable
yeah yeah I mean I went through that as
well I think I I uploaded a live stream
which which was when it all happened and
I was quite like distressed it was like
40 minutes
ranting and of course that's what nerd
city pulled out of is my like really
unfiltered 40 minutes I then released
like a five-minute condensed version
that was when I calmed down a bit but no
for a time I was seriously considering
quitting with like I mean if you are if
you know you if you can't do anything
about your videos being demonetised and
your sponsors won't work with you again
like people something I just I know you
already addressed this but it's really
worth saying again people say okay if
YouTube ads won't appear in your videos
just get sponsors why don't you just get
sponsors look sponsors might not want to
work with you if you're not getting
views well it's the same thing with on
television if you're not getting views
on your if the show is not being viewed
the channels not gonna make money on it
and they're gonna cancel your show so
totally you you need to have views for
some I mean the the deals I work with
are called CPM based deals and in that
way you get paid for every thousand
people who watch your video so it is
directly linked to the views that you're
getting on your videos and so if you if
you get suppressed if you get to
monetize that's not really an option so
yeah it just makes it all the more
frustrating and if that's happening and
you're not making a profit and if you're
if you're an educational channel there's
an animation team and a research team
and a writing team and thousands of
dollars go into the production of each
video that can be a big problem if even
one video gets demonetized
that can be like an entire months worth
of income if you were one of the
creators who are releasing once a month
and not once a day so yeah that could be
at that point you might as well looking
look for something look for something
different because if you don't even know
what the rules are and you can't even
play by the rules and you're being
punished you you can't even play the
game so so I was so I want to tell you
something that I'm not sure of you know
because like nerd City didn't talk I
mean I I think the only video really
about the mature rating is really nerd
cities video so for people D
monetization is one thing there's a
second thing called the content rating
system which is like your video is rated
and it's invisible which is stupid GPG
teen or em and if you're rated in
basically that's when your video gets
suppressed so normally when you see a
demonetised video it's likely that
we'll be in the reason Susan would jiske
can say our content rating system and
our D monetization systems are separate
is because in a very technical sense
they are but it just so happens that the
same rules that get you D monetize are
also going to get you rated in so one
thing that I don't know if you know
Griffin is that rated M has a certain
connotation from how we think of it in
our pop culture that I think isn't
working with YouTube because in pop
culture when you say M you say we don't
want people under 18 watching this video
right here's what's weird about YouTube
and this is what drives me insane
YouTube doesn't mean that when they say
rated M they mean like we're not gonna
recommend it but they don't mean we're
only gonna show it to your over 18
audience because if that was the case
then being rated in would not affect a
channel like mine and probably not yours
I don't know about your demographics but
might well even people even people who
are young lie about their age of course
everyone writes that they're at least 18
ever no and no one like will admit that
they're 8 years old and an if an 8 year
old on e is on a google account they're
probably using their mother so no you
can't really tell who's not 18 most
people are gonna show up as 18 or older
yeah yeah yeah like like my channels
like I have a 5% of my demographic is
under 18 the rest are in like the 18 to
25 and then there's like some older
folks but it's like oh if that if it was
a traditional rating M it's like I would
expect to see maybe a 5% drop in my
views because those people wouldn't be
shown right my recommended video but
that's not what you end up saying you
see a disproportionate amount of
recommendations lost because you know
about like how you can see YouTube's
funnel for how who they're showing your
video to I don't know if you've noticed
this but basically your recommendations
on the watch page go way down you should
you should check it out anyway oh yeah
yeah oh you probably already know it but
but that's what's driving me crazy at
this point because I'm just thinking to
myself like I'm I'm like why if you're
gonna rate videos in okay but let the
people who are mature enough to watch my
videos watch my videos because it's not
really an M rating like you said it's
more like let's kill the video
except for the people who happen to be
going typing in coffee break to YouTube
and happen to see my video or the people
who are like super dedicated fans who
are clicking on their subscription box
for the people who are just getting who
are used to just clicking on my videos
from that from the homepage of the watch
page they're just not seeing it and
they're not seeing your videos they're
not seeing it even if they're 18 yeah
yeah there's just no way and there's
well and also one of the frustrating
things too if you already know this most
creators don't even know this is a thing
so not only is a system that is there a
system in place that is broken but the
system no one even knows about a broken
system which it just makes it doubly
worse so no that's definitely one thing
I like to bring up too is that I mean I
was taught about the Holocaust in like
sixth grade it's like if I don't know
why you need to be eighteen to learn
about history and I'm not even covering
I haven't even talked about the
Holocaust in my on my video I keep
bringing that up because that is what
gets your videos that is like you'll get
the worst rating if you even mention it
even though YouTube explicitly denies
that's the case right yeah yeah or just
just won't even tell you you can't
another thing that's frustrating too is
that I tried to email people I try to
get in contact with YouTube and they do
not give you any for those of you who
think that you like work with some kind
I mean some people work with managers
especially if you're at a really large
scale but those of you even if the
500,000 subscriber range some might
still have managers most probably don't
and yeah you have no one to go to you've
no new you have nobody to ask questions
to and if you try to email YouTube
they're going to send you a template of
please read their terms terms and
conditions and see why your video is
being demonetized and you just click on
it and it's a wall of text that doesn't
help you at all it's just super vague
terminology so yeah that no that's like
the funniest thing to me is when YouTube
sends super basic information and it's
like this helps me this doesn't help me
at all there's a political channel who
is like yeah like my videos my channels
basically been killed because you guys
are killing my recommendations and team
YouTube hops in the chat they're like
have you checked out our creator tips
for how to increase your reach it's
yeah it's so condescending it's like if
you've been on here for three years
you're full time and you've got a half a
million subscribers or a million
subscribers I'm sure you know how to
upload a video and what the description
is and what monetization is like I'm
sure you know all of that and then they
have the audacity to condescend you
unless you're 10 million subscribers
super family-friendly they really I mean
it's kind of like a cliche to say that
they don't care about smaller creators I
won't necessarily say that I'm sure that
the people working there think they care
they think they care about smaller
creators but the systems that are in
place do not cater to the support of
those smaller creators I think that
would be a more accurate way to say I
mean if they yeah
no I think you're totally right and I
don't know if this is the case in the
history community but one thing that
I've noticed is that YouTube the people
they do clearly clearly favor are the
established mainstream voices so one
thing I noticed was I was like looking
up vaping videos because it's like man
how many people are talking about vaping
and like actually well because when you
talk about the teen vaping epidemic
that's what got me kill right okay
because I wasn't promoting baby being
but I was talking about the team vaping
epidemic how dare you talk about that
whatever I went and I looked up a few
news sources and I'm seeing all these
ads run on them because they're
mainstream right so they get greenlit I
don't know if there is like an
equivalent of like a history mainstream
outlet well there are i history is not
as I mean I think the biggest science
science channels are much bigger than
the biggest history channels but the of
the biggest history channels and this
isn't calling these people out in any
way because their fault that they're
their green light here but I think a
channel called simple history they've
got a couple million and oversimplified
have a couple million I think if I'm not
mistaken oversimplified has a two-part
series on Hitler on just Hitler's life
and it's a little a little fun character
of Hitler so like I think and he gets
monetized all of his videos get
monetized simple history can talk about
I think they talked about the the
Italian invasion of Ethiopia and that
might just sound like some random
conflict who cares that that happened
but in the Second World War
if anyone has researched this you'll
know that the Italians won almost solely
be
cuz they're dropping gas canisters and
pretty much breaking every rule in the
Geneva Convention and are like doing
like mass killings of any village that
they come across so it's a pretty
controversial invasion but they will get
monetized pretty easily again that's not
their fault but I think I don't know
what the system does I mean for a little
while when my channel was smaller I had
a video called life in Nazi Germany with
a giant swastika and Hitler and it was
an objective video but it was that that
seems pretty controversial and it wasn't
even flagged for I didn't even have to
do a manual review but that was a couple
years ago and so I think the rules were
different before and I think there must
be some kind of way that the algorithm
kind of checks off certain channels
I don't know how again nothing's
transparent so this is all speculation
but yes some again another weird thing
about it is just that some channels can
cover the same topic
like you said especially the mainstream
and established ones can cover the same
topic and they'll be mean you did a
video on that how the trending page
works and anyone who spent a long time
on YouTube knows that if you go to the
trending page the first thing you'll see
are the late night hosts and Will Smith
and it's like those aren't youtubers
what what is Will Smith doing up here
and let yeah makes he makes good content
whatever I guess if you want to watch
him you want to watch him but it's not
like he's a youtuber I think everyone
can acknowledge that Will Smith is first
but like first is an actor and likewise
all of the late night hosts are not
youtubers and then late night hosts so
the fact that the youtubers themselves
the people who do this as they're like
primary source for like revenue and for
living they're not appearing on the
trending page they're not appearing on
recommended as much a lot of these more
well-established channels and companies
more specifically all right they're
getting green light or like getting if
like not only are they getting green
light but they're getting extra
privileges and being promoted more so
than anyone else it's it's like insult
over injury it's like not only are you
not able to just get the normal
recommendations but these guys who
you're I guess competing with in a way
are not only able to cover whatever they
want but they also get bonus points they
also get to be promoted way more than
everyone else does and you don't know
why you don't know where to look for why
that happens you can only speculate so
again it's just it's all you don't know
what you write and everything is super
frustrating that's like the theme
no that's that no that's exactly right
and the thing is and this is this is
something I've heard sort of around is
that we're YouTube's reviewers are
located are basically the low-income
countries where because they basically
need a they made this promise to have
like 10,000 manual reviewers and scale
up massively and you just can't hire
that kind of workforce in the US is too
costly so where do you go you go to a
place like India or something like that
where there isn't as on average as good
of an understanding of the English
language and so if you're if your video
gets you try to manually review a video
and you're like a low priority Channel
I'm guessing they're not going to be
sending you to their you know California
review team right they're going to be
sending you to their you know wherever
review team and where they don't
understand English as much and they see
some cartoon characters holding guns and
they don't want to be responsible for
that being on the site so they're like
well I guess I'll just get you know D
monetize him whereas if you sent it to a
review team that sort of understood like
the US side of things that context and
understood exactly what you're saying
maybe they would they would greenlight
your video the other thing is I imagine
that the timeframe to make a decision on
these videos is not watch the whole
video and then decide yeah I'm sure it's
like watch 20 seconds watch 20 seconds
scrub through the rest go through the
transcript and make a decision within
like a minute or two minutes or three
and it's that is just not adequate I
think what we're finding is that there
was this idea that machine learning
could scale fast enough to solve these
problems and machine learning like oh we
just give it enough training sets right
and we just give it enough data and it's
gonna get like really really good and
sure it's gotten better but not I mean
almost not though yeah well it's gotten
better in some areas and then we'll take
it'll go ten steps forward and then 20
subs back all of a sudden and then keep
do it's it's very like it's very
volatile like I noticed I was doing
really well and again life in Nazi
Germany okay I didn't I didn't even
really introduce concert
and I covered it objectively okay and I
was monetized and I didn't even have to
contend with the bot okay cool and then
all of a sudden everything gets flagged
and then nothing good I even talked to
another YouTube channel cynical
historian and he just tells me that they
reversed their decisions all the time so
it could be monetized and then D
monetized and then a video year ago
we'll get REME onit eyes again it's like
it is all over the place you can't the
again it's like it's not just that
there's a problem here it's that nobody
knows what the hell's going on like I
don't know if my whole channel is gonna
get to monetize tomorrow it could happen
and and you might although you're over
exaggerating a bit well look at the
great war channel again 250 videos
demonetised I again I don't even have
that many videos on my channel so and I
cover military history almost
exclusively so I could be the next one
on their list and the Great War channel
is bigger than mine so maybe they're
gonna look at my next and take down all
I don't know what's going to happen you
don't know any of this information it's
we just have to try to be yeah well
here's what's great here is what I've
realized has kind of kind of happened
which is really unfortunate so whenever
you have an AI classifier you have two
different kinds of false false things
going on either the thing is monetizable
and it incorrectly D monetizes it or
it's D monetizable and it incorrectly
monetizes those are two mistakes an AI
can make right yeah or it can just
correctly identify so the problem is
that I've noticed is I don't know if you
notice when there was a whole Vox ad
pocalypse
Susan Wojcicki did an interview on
recode with Kara Swisher and or was it
Carrisford anyway it did an interview
where basically the person said look you
guys have garbage on your site you're
promoting garbage and and Susan was like
oh but we're getting so much better and
he goes well if you're even letting
point one percent through you are
failing you're failing the community
you're allowed he goes like if I had
only 1% of my backyard filled with Garth
sludge I would just clear out the whole
yard you know what I mean basically his
point was like you guys need to
completely solve the problem of falsely
monetized it should have been D
monetized okay when you anytime you tell
an AI like
never make a mistake on should have been
demonetised but you monetized it you're
going to automatically just
exponentially increase the number of
should have been should have been
monetized but God D monetized because
you're telling it like B be so cautious
don't let anyone through because if you
let anyone through it's a giant failure
and so what I think we've seen a lot of
is YouTube way overreact to the all the
flack they've been getting from some of
these like mainstream outlets like Vox
and these guys where they're saying look
if we find one Nazi video with six
hundred views we're gonna blow you up or
you know we're gonna go to your
advertisers we're gonna completely kill
you guys
and so YouTube's like well we don't want
that to happen so let's just Ratchet it
the other way you know everyone else be
damned then they just don't have the
manpower to solve problems I mean like
at this point as a creator you just have
to make it like the only solution is not
you don't have nobody has managers they
don't have enough managers so as you
said so it's like what do they do it the
answer is to complain on Twitter it's so
pathetic I mean that's literally what
you said right like you're like hey I'm
gonna go complain on Twitter like come
retweet me because we need to basically
get this solved on my channel right yeah
well don't still be got no response
I mean largely I was very like grateful
because larger YouTube channels reached
out who were giving me a bunch of tips
and that actually helped me out and it
was about how you titled the videos in
the words you put in them and then the
nerd city video came out and pretty much
come on oh that's interesting well but
yeah you too I never got in touch with
YouTube through the entire issue I had
with my channel and I don't think any of
my colleagues have ever gotten in touch
with YouTube either so yeah there's
basically nothing you can do I don't
know it's yeah it's just there's just no
communication on really any you can't
even go to Twitter I mean again if
you've got a massive platform if you're
one of the larger creators you can try
to but even then you notice that even
like maybe it's like h3 h3 or whoever it
is can say something and Twitter's
response or YouTube's response on
Twitter will be like thank you well look
into this shortly and nothing will
happen it's just yeah you're not gonna
you're not gonna be like oh [ __ ] dude
sorry bro I
I screwed up on that one let me take
care of that you're not gonna get like a
person who's going to be doing that so
there's just yeah there's very little
that you can do about it oh I feel like
I feel depressed right now from our
conversation right take a moment where
do we go from here
is there a viable solution coming or is
it all in YouTube's Court what can
creators do let's say you're a History
Channel right now mm-hmm and you're
getting d or you're thinking about
starting one that's even better because
I think that's the real cost of this is
creators who don't have a following who
are trying to build a following look
they're watching what's going on how
volatile the system is what would you
say to someone like that so I feel
really I don't want to be cynical and I
feel really bad saying this I get an
email from someone who wrote this like
very long email out and was saying like
hey I really want to start a History
Channel I'm very excited about it and I
just want some advice from you and
normally I respond to those and like I
just I just deleted the email because I
couldn't I couldn't write to him like
hey don't do it I don't want to be too
cynical but I don't know if I would even
recommend starting a History Channel at
this point I mean really this just goes
to like anything if you're if you're
trying to take a risk in any kind of
entertainment through YouTube or through
becoming a SoundCloud rapper or whatever
you want to do or writing a book you
don't want to do it you don't want to
jump into it full-time you want to do it
as a hobby see if it can go anywhere and
take it very very cautiously that's what
I did before making a decision to stop
finishing my education and completely
pursue the the YouTube channel I guess
my advice would be to be extra cautious
and I don't even I don't know here's
here's something uh I think there is a
way to get around it if you can crowd
fund yourself that's really the only
guarantee you have - what I've realized
after doing this and running it as a
business for a couple years now is
middlemen will if you if you have
middlemen to start you off that's good
maybe you don't you're not big enough to
like do merchandise in-house or
negotiate with a large merchandise
companies to use tea Springs or like
just a like a middleman to get you
started when you get larger and when
you're considering doing things
full-time do not rely on middle
the rule should be you want to look at
like okay is my youtube channel I'll
start my history YouTube channel is it
doing well okay maybe what if I do it do
it full-time before you might say yeah
I'll try it full time and we'll see if
it works YouTube isn't that volatile
well now now that it's gotten even worse
I would say you have to add another rule
to this and say how many middlemen am i
relying on and yes YouTube is a
middleman so if you can directly connect
with an audience who is completely
crowdfunding you and you can survive
entirely off of the income that the
people who are watching you or provide
like that is when you know that things
can be ok so if you want to start a
History Channel don't go into it I mean
this is the same advice I would give
years ago don't go into starting a any
kind of YouTube channel or any kind of
thing that like a podcast or any form of
entertainment without like if you if you
go into it thinking you're gonna make
money on it then that's a wrong way to
think about for sure you end up making
money on it or the people go and do it
for the passion of it and then maybe
because they see how passionate you are
in that the content is good maybe you
can make money off of it but even then
if you start making money off of it
again you have to ask yourself that next
question can how many middlemen can I
cut and how reliable is the middleman of
YouTube into reaching this audience what
I've done is I've started a website
subscription service kind of like a
Netflix for history that I'm still
working on now but we've got like over a
thousand people just in the month that
we've launched moved over to that
supporting us and by 2020 I want that to
be my primary source of income not that
I'm going to stop doing YouTube but I
need to guarantee that if everything
falls apart I'm directly connect to my
connected to my audience so I guess the
bottom line I would say is do what you
want start what you want and make it
into a passion project it's the same
advice I would give before don't go into
it think you're gonna make money but the
new rule is even if you are making money
even if you are making a lot of money
make sure that you have some kind of
base of crowd funding from your audience
that is reliable so that if everything
falls apart you still have people that
can help you because I didn't do that I
didn't I didn't even have a patreon for
a while I still don't have a patreon I
just have my website I think that's
interesting that you chose to build a
website rather than going to patreon
which ruin all the legs which were yeah
right way exactly
I was gonna say which reflects totally
your mentality about middlemen are
unreliable capricious and ultimately you
have no guarantees they give you zero
guarantees
well patreon even removed button again
we have to get the politics of anything
but they removed a bunch of conservative
YouTube channels I believe I don't know
if there were youtubers are just
conservatives and pretty like further
right conservatives I don't know what
the details of the story but regardless
the fact that they removed anybody and I
as far as I know these people weren't
like committing crimes or hurting
anybody they were just they just had
like some kind of like outlandish
political ideas I honestly I don't even
know who exactly up stop my head was
affected by this but the very fact that
they can just get removed and everything
is shut down that's scary and so I did
not want to a have patreon dipped their
hand into every donation I got every
month like I don't want my fans getting
patreon comes in and grabs a percentage
of every fans contribution and I also
don't want them to have the ability to
remove my page at any point not that I'm
going to smother anything controversial
no no let me explain for the audience
it's not just conservatives there was
this there was this girl
Naomi Wu who does like robotics or
something like that she was on patreon
she got a ton of money from patreon she
had some kerfuffle with like some
journalists or whatever she got removed
because she did something that the
patreon didn't like I mean ultimately
it's not just about politics it's just
about if you commit any arbitrary act
and patreon is trying to save face
they're just gonna kick you from their
platform and all those people who made
that voluntary decision to support you
Don yeah and the same thing applies to
YouTube YouTube can just do monetize all
your videos they can shut down as many
videos as they want they can do whatever
so I wouldn't even YouTube has this
thing where you can sign up for YouTube
memberships I'm not doing any of that
I'm you could again I get it for like
smaller channels you don't have the
infrastructure or the reach to be able
to not everyone can crowd fund
themselves not everyone can make it full
living off patreon but I just I like to
think ten moves ahead and I would rather
five years from now have a base of
thousands of supporters on a website
that I control than having thousands of
users who are already signed up through
let's say patreon and by the time I want
to move to starting my own website to
try to get everybody to move over it's
gonna require so much effort so I even
if I'm gonna take a loss for a couple of
years I know that down the road it's
going to be a good decision
just to you just want to have control
over it whether you're going into
starting a youtube channel with a
partner whether you're going into
YouTube channel and just signing up with
tons of middlemen whatever it is just
make sure that nobody has that kind of
leverage of I control your income I own
50 more than 50% of your channel I owned
like you just want to have that's at
least what I think philosophy that I go
by is like I need full control over what
I'm doing I'm not going to sabotage my
channel by like removing all I'm not
it's not like I'm gonna say I'm not
gonna cooperate with anyone I'm gonna do
everything myself that's not the way to
go
you should work with as many people as
you can but when it comes to like your
income and if you may be able to do it
full-time you don't have to rely on
people who can kick you out at any point
you want this is sort of sad though in a
way isn't it like I thought that the
whole idea of YouTube originally was
like we are going to provide the
infrastructure of video hosting and
making money from that video hosting
that was the real innovation for people
the whole innovation of patreon was like
we're gonna provide we're gonna get rid
of the we are gonna be the middleman
from you and your audience and as you
said I think it just erodes trust every
time somebody gets kind of snapped off
the side right but anyways I I don't I
try not to make these episodes too long
for my for my watchers because otherwise
I think we could probably talk all day
about this this is like inside baseball
that creators love but for the fans okay
I just want to I just want to wrap this
up real quick so any last thoughts
questions could surge whatever anything
else you wanted to say I don't think so
I would just say look to try not to be
too cynical about I I reacted at first
by like wanting to take down all my
videos and instantly get off of YouTube
that was my gut reaction but I would
just say don't be too cynical about it
because YouTube has had the ad pocalypse
before and they've gone through problems
but they most of the time they managed
to come back so you shouldn't go into
this thinking everything is doomed to
fail YouTube is going to completely
collapse and you know I just think
whatever you do don't be too cynical
about it but also remain cautious and
make sure that no one
that kind of leverage of you financially
or like they don't control your audience
you have somewhere established you've
been starting a discord for your
audience just getting it to you want to
just as like creator kind of like
insight you want to connect with your
audience as much as you can and build up
a direct relationship with really
working with you don't want people like
even like if you're in sales or
something you're not gonna put a bunch
of middlemen it you want to know who
your customers are and as much as you
can so the reason that live streams do
so well are the live stream is are able
to make it is that they interact with
their audience and they make it fun for
them to watch and they're engaging with
them directly so if you're gonna start a
YouTube channel if you already have a
YouTube channel and you're afraid of
this just find ways to connect with your
audience more and really make it less
about YouTube handling everything and
make it about you really establishing
that kind of fan base and people who
want to watch your content and support
you and just be just be very just I
think the final note I want to say is
just because a bunch of other youtubers
say something or do something doesn't
mean you have to do it if they're all
doing YouTube memberships or YouTube or
patreon or whatever it is just consider
all of your options and if everybody
else is jumping ship it doesn't mean
that they're necessarily right just look
into something for yourself and don't
just don't even just listen to this one
video and make a final decision you want
to make sure that you're like
well-informed about a situation before
you do something drastic kind of like
what I did on the first day of just like
I'm gonna take out all my videos you
just want to take that time to really
consider what's going on and you know
have a little perspective and know that
YouTube's gone through ups ups and downs
and that this isn't the end of the world
people like to have the mentality of
like okay they did one thing and
everything's gonna fall apart we're
gonna be gone in five years I think
it'll be okay we just have to keep
pushing pushing through it and I think
videos like these and conversations that
open up and creators sharing insight
about how they get around D monetization
I think things like that helped and you
know a lot of larger creators reached
out to me about how to help out with
your monetization which has been working
so far so great I think having
conversations just doing that kind of
research before you jump ship and panic
is is always it good I mean that applies
to really anything just but yeah I guess
I landed on that
a man listen to the McCord space and him
from straight smacking of a war I was on
the plane and the stewardess said that's
foolishness so for that meet I can't
wait
[Music]
[Music]